families who have been harmed telling us
about service failures that the NHS
should have known about first and did
not
in carrying out the investigation
I've kept that in mind as much as but
not more than what has actually happened
in East Kent
what has happened in these Kent is
deplorable and harrowing
we have numerous instances of care that
was not
given to the right standards
consistently failed to meet standards
with deaths and significant harm in
schools of families
it had 202 families that came forward in
97
deaths injuries or other harm could have
been different if care had been given to
the standards accepted nationally
in 45 of the 65 stillborn and
newborn babies who died
they could have had a different outcome
had care been given to the standards
accepted accepted nationally
as well as that we found that there had
been frequent instances where a
significant harm was caused to people's
well-being
by the unkind and callous way on
occasions that they were treated and
some have been deeply affected by that
many have been deeply affected by that
we haven't found that there's been a
single clinical cause of the failure
what we've found is four underlying
themes that led directly to these
problems
the first is Extreme failures of
teamworking as you know maternity care
has to be delivered by groups of
professionals working together from
different
backgrounds from different professions
they have to work together effectively
they did not and there are various
reasons for that including lack of trust
and lack of respect but there is also
inescapably the fact that professionals
can sometimes
get the impression that they're working
to different goals
it might be to reduce the amount of
intervention or it might be to not
reduce the amount of intervention a team
that works to different goals in my view
is not a team